- [Gary] You're about to
listen to something,
and you'll see how me
and my crew here in the room,
manifested throughout it.
Something that we think is a
ridiculous piece of content,
and I think you'll
be seeing a bunch more.
This is a Reddit Q&amp;A session.
And I think we'll be
doing more Q&amp;A sessions
across other platforms.
And more Reddit
as well, over time.
I hope you enjoy it.
Audio, enormously
passionate about audio.
Believe that
podcasting and Alexa skills,
and the Google home platform.
I believe that audio
is gonna save humans time.
Which is why
it's super valuable.
And is not only my number one,
but it's my number two and three
trend that I'm obsessed with.
You need to get
your music heard.
So, the best way, is to actually
make good hip hop music.
Because if your
product sucks, you're finished.
But if we assume
that you're good,
I would reach out
and DM on Instagram,
every person
that creates content,
and offer your
music for free to them
to be playing in the background,
so that you can siphon
their audience's awareness
to hear your music.
And for them, they're
getting the music asset
that may make
their videos better.
You have to bring people value.
I let zero minutes waste.
You know one of the
things, there's a lot of.
You don't have
to type this part,
but I like I
guess this is for this.
I like the new faces.
The thing that I think
you learn pretty quickly,
is like, "Wait a minute,
"this is even more
ridiculous than I thought".
It's just basically
fucking 15 straight hours.
Like where the fuck is...
Like when does he drink water?
Like when does he take a piss?
Like when does he eat something?
I don't!
- [Man] You're a robot.
- But I'm a robot.
But like, the
punchline is, like that's it.
Now that's my bar,
I don't expect
anybody to reach my bar.
But the reality is,
the results are
correlated to the work.
- [Man 2] Do
they have to create
their own tasks for themselves?
- If they're
that kind of person.
I've definitely
maximized my efficiency
by having a full time assistant,
where I like...
I'm a complete
slave to my calendar,
which I am then the boss
of, through my assistant.
Which then forces it to
be maximized every minute.
- [Man 2] Meaning
there's always something
to do if they create it.
- If you were watching a
Youtube video for 11 minutes,
randomly in the day.
You've already wasted
more time than I have,
any day for the last
fucking five, seven, nine years.
Like, that's it, go ahead.
I would have gone out a
couple times and hooked up.
- [Man 2] This is a big one.
- I'm serious, I'm pissed.
- [Tyler] Thursday night?
(mumbles)
- You got a date?
- [DRock] No!
- He's been sliding into the DM.
For myself, that
I have the stunning.
My funeral will be
attended by far more people
than anybody realized.
That's for me.
For my company,
that I build one of the great,
entrepreneurial media
business empires of all time.
And for the world,
that it continues
to do what it's doing.
Which is at a macro,
it always,
always, always is better
than it was the day before.
Even if the headlines trick
you into not believing that.
It will be far bigger than most
people think in five years.
Billions, and billions,
and billions, and billions.
Put four billions.
In 10 years, it
will be understood,
and be trillions, and
trillions, and trillions
of business.
In 20 years, I don't know.
But it will probably
start feeling like television,
which is trillions and trillions
and trillions of dollars,
but not as
effective as it's going to be
over the next 20 years.
It will be a mature market,
which means it will
be priced appropriately,
or more likely, overpriced.
I'd try as many
things as possible,
and get into the yes business,
instead of the no business.
They've decided what
they're not gonna do,
or what they can't do,
instead of focusing on what
they could potentially do.
Some good ass content.
Right?
This is gonna be
an awesome podcast.
What's up podcast?
I'm not sure
when I'd really talked
about college ambassadors.
I mean, the
punchline here, is being like,
influencers with audience,
or influence, or attention,
is what I trade on.
And so, what I'm looking for
is to give that
person value that they value,
and to extract
value that I value,
where both parties are happy.
The thing I love
about influencer marketing,
I want you to put this.
The thing I love
about influencer marketing
is that influencers
go out to dinner
with their friends, and
they laugh at the person
that just paid them $3,000 to
put a picture on Instagram,
and the people
that are best at it,
go out to
dinner that same night,
and laugh that
that person posted it
on Instagram for $3,000.
That was fucking cool, actually.
I don't outsource work.
I haven't dug fully into it,
but intuitively, Medium
and Ev Williams,
the guy behind Medium,
is something I would bet
on every day of the week.
So, when I get around to like
digging a little further,
my intuition is I'll
find something I like.
And holistically,
I like Medium a lot.
Actually, that's one of the
things I'm most excited about,
is getting that
game going again.
- [Man 2] I'm ready.
- Good, I could tell.
I think it's still important
if you can produce
great written content.
I stopped because I didn't
have a writer on my team,
but now I do, perfect timing,
I'm about to
fucking explode on my blog.
That's a great Reddit question.
But a shitty question to ask me,
'cause it's not something
I think I can actually answer.
I'm not sure.
The truth is, the
reason I love Q&amp;A,
is 'cause I want to bring
more value to other people,
and a lot of people do Q&amp;A
so that they ask them questions
that brings that person value.
And I think that's fucked up.
Yeah. (laughs)
I am completely driven by the
chip on my shoulder as well.
I love doing it to stick it
to people who slept on me.
But I also do it...
I do it out of the
guilt and the gratitude I have
for the talents
I was given, 100%.
I am completely
and utterly blown away.
I just basically
think I'm no different
than LeBron or Beyonce, right?
I was given something, for real.
And so now I feel
guilty and grateful.
So I have to do it.
For the game.
100%.
I have to stay alive.
Brandon Warnke,
Brandon Warnke, yep.
Is my best friend,
and is the best thing
I ever did a Wine Library.
That's my answer.
My home screen is
mainly social sites.
And Nuzzle
and my calendar.
The home screen
that I most want is
the collective home screen of
every 15-year-old in America.
- Why?
- Because I want to
know what one or two things
they're doing that
I don't understand yet,
then I can
manifest into thesis-es
that will bring me opportunity.
Mushing words together.
That made a lot of sense
to me, actually, weirdly.
That was such a.
You know why I reacted that way?
That's so the truth.
Moving on, I don't
pander to negativity.
I don't care about money.
I do recommend it.
If your ambition speaks to it.
What I mean by that is,
if you want big things,
you have to be able
to take the risk
of wasting your time,
because the
upside is, if tomorrow,
Snapchat comes out with
a feature that crushes it
and gets super hot again,
everybody who
jumped off of Snapchat
because of Instagram Stories,
is going to be sad.
And that's what happened to a
lot of people with Facebook.
Facebook had a lull
back in like '11, you know.
And so, yeah,
I recommend it
based on your ambition,
based on your skill, right?
If you can't write,
then it's hard to be
good at Medium and blogging.
Right, but I'm a big fan
of buying in your strengths,
so whether it's audio,
video, or written word,
you gotta pick on of those if
you're capable of all of them.
If you have the capability
and the ambition, all of them.
What's so cool about that is
it's my actions
speak to my words,
right, like,
look what I've done.
I've built a
crazy infrastructure
over the last year around that.
Now, it took me
eight years to be able to
even afford the first person.
Eight years.
Eight years I did everything.
- Should someone go
all-in on one platform?
- I'm not against it, but
I sure don't like the feeling
of being
vulnerable to a platform.
It'd really suck if
Facebook decided tomorrow
to make Instagram's
organic reach 1%.
Not for me.
Because I've siphoned the
value of brand out of them.
I'm not at the mercy,
it's why I don't think that
everything has to be by email.
I'm not at the
mercy of the platform
because I'm not transactional.
I don't sell, that way.
It's not about how many
views this photo's gonna get
for this sneaker shout-out.
It's that I'm GaryVee.
I built a brand.
I personally use doing
by creating and putting out,
and then watching what happens.
I use my intuitive
nature to figure that out.
A lot of other people
use hardcore analytics.
I believe that
analytics, often times,
tells you what already happened,
not what to do next.
I think the
interpretation of the streets,
and analytics, and
word-of-mouth,
and a quick conversation,
my intuitive nature, is
why I've been successful
because I'm
feeling what to do next,
not quantifying
what happened before.
By executing, by
spending all your time
in worrying about everybody
accepting you in the industry
before you've done anything,
and blaming it on
your age is horse shit.
I mean, Kobe and Lebron were 18.
They got the NBA to pay
attention because they executed.
And other 18-year-olds that came
straight out of
high school didn't.
It's just the fuckin' results.
The quickest way to
tell somebody's a loser
is if they're blaming it on
something, especially their age.
By learning how
to say yes and no.
And what that means is
you're only a
pushover if you allow it.
I think my leverage, I think
it's the ultimate leverage
to be able to give more,
and always give more,
and learn how to take,
not at the expense of
the people who you're giving,
but to the macro of it all,
like, the overall
karma and practicality.
I'm willing to give to
somebody left and right
just because I know what
they're saying behind my back
is most likely
to be quite positive
that can manifest
in a different way.
It's not
transactional with them.
I don't look at
anybody here transactionally,
I look at it as a macro.
No.
(group snickering)
Very zero.
I'm uncomfortable with it
'cause I'm deadly competitive,
and I feel like I don't
wanna be a hypocrite,
and make pretend that
I'm friends with them.
I'm cordial, 'cause
I think respect is real,
but don't get it twisted.
If you compete with me, I wanna
slice your fuckin' throat.
- Madden.
(group laughter)
By not trying to convince them.
Just go to as many of
them until one of them
just believes you
without you convincing them.
Never sell people.
Selling the unsellable
is the stupidest
strategy of all time.
The health of my family.
To realize how lucky they are
that they realize
they should start over,
or how lucky that they
are that they were forced
to start over at an age where
they're still a fuckin' baby.
Man, you know
I've been hot on this,
I know a lot of you
guys know my content.
Like, I'm looking at you guys,
especially the
new dudes in here,
if you guys fuckin'...
Man, if you guys
knew that I actually think
you're my friend
and we're the same age,
it would fuck
with you at a level
that you would not believe.
If you actually knew that
I just think,
like, we're friends,
like, this is normal, right?
But I remember, my
cousin is only eight...
You know Bobby, right?
Jake, Bobby's only,
my cousin's only
eight years older than me,
and when I got
out of school at 22,
he was in the liquor store too,
he was the manager,
and I came up,
like, he was 30, I was 22.
I thought this motherfucker
was so old, (group chuckles)
I'm like, "This
dude is fuckin' old."
Like, right?
So, like, I sit here and I'm 41,
and some of you
guys are this age,
and I'm like, "Holy shit,
they must think I'm so old."
And I think we're
friends. (group chuckles)
It's crazy.
- [Man 2] What
is it about you that...
- Oh, by the way, where
I was going with that was,
then you would
kick into patience.
Like, you would buy
what I'm selling blindly.
If you knew that
it felt that way,
and you could do
everything you wanted,
hook up with girls,
have fun, go to things,
if you knew, if you
knew that it doesn't go away,
that it actually
gets more leverage,
if you knew,
you would fuckin'...
You would fuckin' eat patience
instead of fuckin' spit it out.
I don't know.
Let's go around, Tyler?
- [Tyler] What
is it about you...
- Yeah, what
about me frustrates you?
Tell the truth.
- [Tyler] I'm trying to think.
- Who's got somethin'?
Go ahead, Sid.
- [Sid] Getting time with you.
- Yeah, (group chuckles)
that's for sure.
That I know for fact.
I'm the bottleneck
and access to me
is a real, real, real challenge.
- [Sid] I think it's
funny how you have, like,
five of the case samples
with 60 Second Club winners,
yet someone on
your team's, like,
really lucky to get one
minute with you, you know?
- That's exactly right.
I think about that all the time,
that I have more time for things
that perceive to
be not as important,
because I'm pulling
from opposite directions.
It's really interesting
how it manifests, right?
It's so fuckin' counter...
Everything's counterintuitive.
For most, right?
It's mine.
That's why I don't
get hyped on myself,
I just got the wiring
that just wanted to go left
when everybody goes right.
That's it, there's nothing else.
It's my normal, just like
other people's normal is like,
"This is what you do."
- It's in the
Entrepreneur article,
that everything
you've done is predicated
on people laughing at you,
on the upfront.
- I love that feeling, man.
I love when
people think I'm wrong.
That's when I know
I'm so fuckin' right.
Believing in my intent.
That's the real answer.
You're gonna die.
- [Man] That's true.
- It was so funny that
it happened that one time.
Have you guys seen,
you guys saw that clip?
Do you know what
I'm talking about?
I was leaving a conference,
it was like real
like, fucking like rocks,
like, it was the first
time I like got my mob.
It was like a
Bieber-like thing, it was crazy
and I was leaving in the car,
and somebody
even ran up to that,
so I like slid down the window
and she was like, "Just
three words to live by,"
I had no, I was like,
I'd never said it before,
I'm like, "You're gonna die,"
and I like forced
people, like, that's four,
because if you are
gonna die, I'm like, "Cool."
(group laughter)
"Great," I go, "but..."
In that moment, she caught,
like that's, I figured it out.
That's what I believe, that's
what I think is gonna happen,
I think most of us would agree,
thus the pressure's
on to do shit.
Real, important question here,
the same info that
I have actually right now
or, okay, let's say
it's a market.
- Let's say it's a market.
- If everything's the
same and I have all my info,
but I have nothing,
I've already won,
'cause it's the IP
in my head that, right.
What I would do
is take what I, like,
if I had no money,
I'd steal something
and then sell it
on Ebay or Amazon
and then use that
profit to keep selling,
like I would sell my way to
six figures and then start.
It's kind of the
story of my life,
it's so funny,
it's what I did, right,
like I sold, I sold and
then I started realizing,
"Wait a minute,
I'm bigger than that.
"I'm not just a sales
person, I'm an operator,"
and then I'm like, "Wait a
minute, I'm bigger than that.
"I'm a culture hacker,
attention, I got something,"
right, so I would kind
of play the same playbook.
I'd go to my rawest
simplest thing, which is...
If I literally had zero,
I'd steal something,
that's just the truth (laughs)
or you know
what, I hate stealing,
I'd probably go to Craig's List
and see people
putting out shit for free.
Right, like just probably
walk around neighborhoods,
depending on if I have a
car, because I have no money,
I'll go really raw,
just go in rich neighborhoods
and walk around,
until I see somebody
put out something in the
garbage, that's worth money.
I don't know, 'cause
I haven't had a family tragedy
at a scale enough to
answer that question.
By having them come to you,
so what I would do is
I would spend a ton of time
going to affluent art gatherings
or internet places,
where they hang
and I would listen
and listen and listen
and try to find patterns of
what they actually go for.
I would also give away my art
to affluent people at scale,
until the guilt of the free
gifts created the leverage,
that created my
first buying customers.
This is a difficult
question without more context,
but I would say
to give an answer,
I would say start
off by doing 50-50
for just a, you know,
couple of months,
just to taste the results,
but make sure it's obvious
to you what the results are.
That there's a lot of people
out there that like to read
and that I want
people to hear my shit.
Fuck, we should do this
again, I mean, this is good.
- [Man 3] It is really good,--
- Yeah, this is, yeah, yeah,
- [Man 3] this is
working at every start.
yeah, we need, we
should, this is really,
I mean, this
podcast, hey, podcast peops,
this is fucking
good, right? (laughing)
Ping me up on Twitter right now
and just say, "It's good,"
(Alex laughs)
not even hashtag,
but you can do that too,
it'll help me find
'em easier, it's good.
I don't really have
that process, you know,
I don't know, like,
poop, shower, check my email.
- [Andy] App store?
- I do, but like
I'm like done saying it,
like fucking enough with that.
I mean there's, look,
there's a million ways,
to build a successful business,
you have to sell something,
either as a coach, you're
gonna be selling your time,
you're selling a product,
you know, you're
selling a service,
like, whatever
comes more natural to you.
Obviously products
are the most scalable,
because they
don't require your time.
I vet the people, that
I work with 100% intuitively
and then I judge on the
reality of what happens next.
So as quickly as I hire,
I'm willing to
fire pretty quickly,
not as fast, but pretty quickly.
One trend that I'm glad is over,
I'm glad that it
seems that people
are no longer using tragedies
to build up
their following count.
In the early days of
Twitter, people would say,
"Retweet this and I'll
donate a dollar to Haiti,
"or for every
follower I get on Twitter,
"I'll donate one dollar
to the Manchester massacre."
That shit used to
drive me batshit crazy,
that you needed
something as selfish and vain
as a follow count for
you to do the right thing
was the
quickest way, that I knew
that I never wanted
to talk to you again.
That shit still pisses me off.
What kind of fuck face do
you need to be to be like,
"Hey, there's an
earthquake in Haiti.
"These people are
struggling, it's devastating,
"but let me get a
quick 500 followers
"on Twitter out
of it, real quick
"and then I'll give
500 dollars to Haiti,"
you fucking piece of shit.
- [Man 4] Even people
just riding the hashtag,
just to get sympathy, I guess.
- Anyway, go ahead.
- I would give away my
apparel free, at scale,
to people that have attention,
like influencers on Instagram.
I would even be willing to
pay them if I had the money.
The bigger the influencer, the
more likely I'll have to pay.
(Alex chuckles)
I dominate.
(group laughter)
It's just fucking true.
I mean, I dominate.
- Why do you say that?
- I say it because
I know it's true.
What's given me
more audacity to say it
is a kid was in a
meeting at UTA, who's a fan,
and they were there for
other clients who are in,
you know, in the,
or for UTA or Dafun,
I don't remember who it was for,
I don't know if
it's Jessica, Will, or,
I don't know who,
what it was there for,
but they were watching it.
Maybe it was just a
propagate meeting, I don't know.
But, I didn't have that
context, but they're like,
"Hey, we're in here watching it,
"and all these people are like
"who the fuck is this
dude, he's a fucking star."
And they have no
vested interests.
CAA telling me I crushed,
it means dick shit to me.
- Was it more so, just
the people you brought on, or?
- I just, we teach, have
you seen the first episode?
- No.
- I fucking dominate.
- Bobby Glennon.
- He's probably
hitting it west soon.
- If you think that you
can come in and save the day,
and the family will
give you the air cover,
and you know what to do, you
go help the family business.
But those are two
massive fucking if's.
Yeah, by the way,
on a very serious note,
I don't know who
takes the lead here,
if we go through
Andy, this could be,
actually, you
know what I'm gonna
just give it to you, Sid,
'cause I feel you could do more,
and you're
crushing it, but I just like
expanding rubber bands.
I think this is
so ridiculously good,
and I think we all know this.
We need to do this a lot, but
here's what we need to do,
I love Reddit, I'm
obsessed with Reddit,
but there's also a
lot of other platforms
that are Q&amp;A-ing
now, whether it's Quora,
whether it's like
these other media sites
that are trying to do it.
Get me the State of the Union.
By the way, if
anybody's watching right now,
actually, fuck you, Sid.
Anybody watching on
livestream right now,
if you, actually I also don't
wanna make a bunch of people
do the same work,
how do I do this?
Jake, keep watching right now.
If somebody catches
your eye on Instagram
that really is
committed to doing
five to 15 hours of research
against the State of the Union
of Q&amp;A on the internet,
like where can it be done,
what's the right way,
like give me the landscape
of the 47 platforms that are
doing it, where's the upside?
I wanna pick one
person, but then, I don't wanna
just get work for free, we're
gonna fly that person here,
and they're gonna jam
with us for a day as well,
so we can give way more value
than the five to ten hours
of research.
Your call, Jake Benrubi, on
the random, like who's yes?
Who's gonna sell you,
Jake Benrubi, on like
the person that you
believe will actually put
the 15 hours of work?
And if you wanna pick
two or three people, Jake,
and then call them,
but like I need it, okay?
She is the head of
what most people consider HR,
but we treat HR here
as offense versus defense.
I think HR in a lot
of big organizations is
like people that fuckin'
suck shit and like fire you
and like fuckin' are
holders of the politics
and just like
really work for the CFO
which means that money trumps
everything, this and that.
She's the reverse which
is like the good behaviors,
the lack of politics, the being
the bigger man and woman,
the only things that
I really give a shit about.
She's the infrastructure
that it's built around
because she's the
person that I intuitively trust
the most in the
world to do that.
Obsessed.
Time is the most valuable thing.
AI is built on the
thesis of saving us time,
but the people that
try to use it too far
and eliminate the
human element will lose.
I think it's the
people that use AI to get us
to third and
fourth, fifth's base
and then put the person in
a position to close it out.
That's where I
think the magic upside is.
Ironically if you
read The Thank You Economy,
a lot of that is played out
there six, seven years ago,
I just didn't have the
foresight to understand AI
and things of that nature.
Not to me, but I'm motivated,
but I'm not looking
for, but I think everybody
potentially can be
a motivation, right?
I mean I think
so many people deal
with so many
adversities on a daily basis,
that I'm motivated by
people who can deal with,
anybody on Earth
right now that is positive
that has a terminal illness
is the most inspiring person
to me in the world.
Everyone of them.
That's fucking insane,
do you know how
amazing that person is?
Not from what I've seen,
though confidence
can be siphoned
and then that leads
to some variation of it.
So I don't know
if it's charisma,
and everybody defines
these things differently,
but what I can tell you
is I have absolutely watched
in the last 20 years,
the people that get closest
to me, siphon my confidence
and manifest it in their world
and it's been fascinating
for me to watch.
- [Tyler] We have
two more questions.
- See, look at fucking Tyler.
The confidence to
fuckin' deploy that statement
with that gusto, he didn't
have that shit six months ago.
He woulda been like,
"What about two more questions?"
(laughing)
- [Tyler] Just wait
for the next six months.
- What's that?
- Just wait for
the next six months.
- I know, I'll be
workin' for you in six months.
(laughing)
Did everybody say
never like in their heads?
'Cause that's what I said.
(group laughter)
They can't.
Scratching my intuition.
The truth is, I just
felt like it was right.
It was the way the
organization was one of
the right vehicles
for me to give back
on the thing that
I value the most, my time.
Most of that had
to do with Adam Braun,
but it's manifested
above and beyond that.
- [Tyler] Sweet.
- That was fucking awesome.
(upbeat music)